bonjour à tous alors oui je sais je suis
l'un des derniers sur terre à ne jamais
en fait de top un solo sur fortnight
c'est la honte
je suis carrément trop nul mais
aujourd'hui je vais essayer de me
concentrer je vais faire une session
spéciale où je vais try hard
je vais jouer le mieux possible avec
vous en direct sur twitter pour essayer
de faire le premier top un solo de toute
ma vie je croise les doigts
soyez avec moi encourager moi ça se
passe maintenant les gars on est parti
pour une première partie ça intérêt à
être énorme et sec
ma souris bakou c'est une très très
belle razer que je vous montre regarder
une très très belle razer assez
classique
c'est grâce à elle que je fais très peu
de teint hâlé let's go j'ai pris une
zone complètement et personne n'a le
petit ne fait rien je crois j'ai pas
joué depuis quelques temps mais c'est
justement qu'on n'a pas joué depuis
longtemps que ce soit un taux qui se
passe on va pas commencer à appeler ses
ministres à voir ce que ça donne
on va faire des petits bars et calmement
comme d'habitude chars mal de crâne
synthé d'où vient un peu flatteuse
pierre girier vendredi vers j'ai bougé
d'être sorti il a fait quoi c'est pour
moi indispensable de le savoir sinon je
vais très très mal dormir c'est
nécessaire à pistolet m'apprécient aller
non merci les partiels tsar et visa vous
êtes dans les parcelles en ce moment
c'est chaud j'avais oublié ce mot quoi
le mot partiel c'est un mot qui me donne
des boutons personnellement c'est très
heureux de ramener l'école je vous le
dis même si finalement on n'arrête
jamais travaillé dans la vie un ok on
encourage à dreyer qui doit rendre un
mémoire de 40 pages de petites bottes
d'un youtuber rime avec chômeurs
ça dépendra pas toujours mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut la chance sur ça marche c'est
sûr bon peut-être faire des choses que
calmement là un petit peu arias qui a
osé tirer la m
mon dieu ce qui l'était insein ok j'ai
fait mon premier kilo la journée je
pouvais dire qu'il n'est pas dégueulasse
voilà c'est comme ça que me desbiens
basque où la pièce doit sa deuxième
qu'il apparemment les gens me cherche
des noises je crois qu'ils ont mal
compris qui j'étais en fait moi je joue
comme ça tout le temps ça vous dérange
pas cette habituée peut-être pas des
gens mais font aucun dégât justin ultra
frager j'en ai plus rien à secouer
c'est parti pour un formidable top one
les féroe quantité de prendre sa 9è ça
m'intéresse j'avais pas vu la zone ça
c'est chiant on va effectuer nos by très
calmement
voilà comme ceux ci les frérots on en a
plus rien à [ __ ] ou son mode carrière
je vous le demande
alors là j'ai fait un tout très cool
regard des pratiques malin qu'on n'a pas
le temps en fait on va se la jouer bien
caché on va vraiment chercher le temps
par là vraiment je serai donc avec la
barre qui construit il faut les laisser
centre suit en fait du monde là
je suis mal parti la tâche tout le monde
me voit en fait ça qui est chiant j'ai
pas peur des munitions pour rien ce sera
bon dommage d'ailleurs tu remplaces très
bien je sais même pas d'où ils tirent la
maca où il a vraiment la savait le
sniper marché lourd j'aime que mes
s'appelle l'art est sa place et mois et
demi moi je fais s'approcher des bêtises
moi ouais c'est de faire un petit truc
un peu bizarre comme ça en les comptes
face sièges bon ben voilà on n'est pas
dégueulasse on a deux petits frag
on est pas mal on va essayé de la jouer
comme on a expliqué c'est à dire très
safe est d'accord avec la il sait que je
sais la la connerie serait de prendre un
headshot
donc je vais vraiment calmé merci pour
merci pour le titre semble assez cool a
annoncé martin qui s'est abonnée merci
martin du standard on l'applaudît
siouplait je fais des prix de rigoles là
on ya de l'action ça se passe derrière
les arbres
si personne c'est juste faty sim qui se
passe est-ce que ça va être le premier
toit pas ou pas il reste cinq et demi
excusez moi j'irais bien dans la baraque
district et du monde là bas
merlier de là bas
c'est pas du tout que j'avais dans la
baraque je pense et ce tir de suse
parfait j'en profite monde maranon la
maison n'est pas dans la zone bien comme
je me cassais fuite
[Musique]
j'arrive à notre héros l'agente au
palmarès du les frérots
[Musique]
je
mike à mon premier tabac est effectuée
ce moment est historique
hier [ __ ] c'est mon premier top en
solo après un an de forme nice
waouh c'est un truc de ouf c'est là j'ai
pas j'ai pas les mots ça tue [ __ ] les
amis je vais jusqu'au bout la [ __ ] je
serai content c'est au dessus pour un
screenshot comment fait ce qu'il soit à
imprimer cran la statue je pense que tu
as mérite quand même un petit débrief
objets qu'elle fait 4 frags
donc je l'enregistré highlights équipe
et moi ça les a bien ce que c'est pas
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on fait ceci
en plus ces [ __ ] c'était un peu
merdique un cette dernière se viander
qu'il a il est un peu pour rien ah là là
c'est trop cool c'est trop trop bien
futin c'est génial je pensais que
j'étais pas bon en fait je crois que là
j'ai fait 4 kg de pain à prévoir on en
parle merci yann pour le austin ont
finalement tu vois c'est des viewers qui
sont venus après si un gros gaming
adroitement qu'il a way le dernier dans
les coulisses d'un 74 donc c'était pas
un petit coin raison on va faire un truc
très simple on va simplement les voir
regardez ça au fil à ok une victoire en
solo je pense qu'on peut on peut
apprécier ce chiffre là-dessus a envoyé
quand j'ai vu marquettois pas j'ai fait
je m'habitue à ça
bon bah c'est pas ce truc ah ouais
certes pas jamais fait n'hésitez pas
envoyez ce clip à tous vos potes le top
1 a été effectuée merci de m'avoir
encouragé de m'avoir donné cette force
ce moment est vraiment historique je ne
l'oublierai jamais suivez moi sur ma
chaîne twitch switch pointe et vesta
shturman stream je joue régulièrement le
mardi soir et le dimanche en fin d'après
midi et soirée voix s'appelle le stream
dominical donc venez nombreux on s'amuse
bien on se retrouve bientôt pour une
prochaine session de jeu vidéo
electronic je vous apprécie énormément
ciao
[Musique]